spider-man no way home was worth the
wait but what's going on with that
ending and what are we supposed to take
away from those post-credits scenes near
the end of no way home is determined
that the only way doctor strange can
reverse his earlier tampering with a
multiverse is to cast a second spell
this time one where everybody everywhere
forgets that peter parker ever existed
it's an agonizing decision but one pete
accepts for the good of humanity a
strange caster spell our hero has a few
remaining moments to say goodbye first
to the other spiderman who helped out
and became like brothers then to the
closest thing he has left to real family
ned and mj peter shares a tender
tear-filled moment with mj where she
urges him to reintroduce himself after
her mind has been wiped peter promises
he will after the spell is cast peter
walks the streets like a ghost he is no
longer bothered by strangers no longer
hunted by j jonah jameson but he also no
longer has anyone who loves him looks in
on him or even knows he is alive
of course the temptation is too strong
to not immediately go to the coffee shop
where mj works there peter has a big
speech prepared but one he promptly
abandons when he finds ned and mj
celebrating their acceptance into mit
the dream college that spider-man's
drama previously had them excluded from
speaking briefly with mj it's clear that
the duo still have that same chemistry
we recall from the other spider-man home
films but this time rather than leaning
into it peter thinks it's best if he
keeps his distance nevertheless that
look on mj's face when we last see her
might indicate that there is some spark
of recognition
what are you hiding peter
now peter has a place of his own and a
chance to start over spider-man seems
likely to once again be on the verge of
putting the neighborhood back into
friendly neighbourhood spider-man
drawing parallels to the spider-man
incarnations who came before him tom
holland's peter parker is forced to wake
up to the realities of criminal behavior
but this time rather than an uncle ben
he loses an aunt may in the previous
home movies uncle ben has never been
mentioned leaving it ambiguous where the
holland's peter parker suffered the
go-to tragedy for spider-man's typical
origin stories aside from some initials
on a suitcase and a vague line in
homecoming saying he can't reveal his
superhero identity to aunt may quote
with everything that's happened to her
or a quick acknowledgement of ben in the
what if series the character hasn't
really existed in the mcu this point is
driven home in no way home when peter
meets two other spider-man played by
toby maguire and andrew garfield of
course who both share their uncle ben's
stories and he doesn't seem to find
common ground with them instead his
grief emanates from green goblin killing
may her final words before he realized
the severity of her injuries with great
power there must also come great
responsibility in the ensuing scenes we
see holland's peter parker grappling
with various stages of grief even giving
in to his bloodthirsty impulses as he
nearly beats norman osborn to death
after spending much of the film trying
to save his life eventually the other
two spider-men convinced him to walk a
gentler path with toby maguire's peter
parker even stopping him from impaling
goblin with his own glider and goblin
lives to go home unfortunately mae
doesn't after doctor strange cast his
spell making everyone forget about peter
parker one of peter's first moves is to
visit his aunt's gravestone while there
he just happens to find himself standing
alongside happy hogan who is still
distraught over the death of his
girlfriend but now oblivious to not only
peter's identity as spider-man but who
peter even is the slate has been wiped
clean tony stark's mentorship all that
incredible technology a safety net happy
seemed to provide whenever peter found
himself in trouble it's all gone and now
peter is back to square one as
spider-man which in essence would seem
to indicate it's time to go buy himself
a new red hoodie the famous spider-man
pointing meme originated from an episode
of the 60s animated series where a
villain dresses as spider-man resulting
in some corny confusion
there can't be two spiderman
the meme isn't explicitly referenced in
no way home possibly because spider-man
into the spider-verse already made the
joke but with three spider-man running
around it isn't for lack of opportunity
despite andrew garfield's insistence to
the contrary he is in the film and so is
toby mcguire both playing peter parker's
from the different universes but their
film franchises took place at the end of
nowhere home when pete and doctor
strange finally figure out a way to send
everyone home this not only includes the
villains but also those other guys in
the red and blue pajamas so after a
teary goodbye holland peter parker sees
garfield peter and maguire peter return
to their own realms yeah maguire got
stabbed which initially seemed like some
matter of concern but apparently he's
going to go home find himself a really
big band-aid and have his mj make him a
nice big bowl of chicken soup hey we're
here to explain the ending not
nitpicking
spider-man no way home features a pair
of very cool post-credits sequences the
first piggy backs off venom let there be
carnage specifically it follows up on
that film's post-credits scene which
seems to indicate an impending
convergence of the venom and spider-man
franchises in the no way home credit
scene eddie brock is a few drinks deep
and wearing a mexico cap as he grills a
bartender at the resort in the mcu after
learning about iron man hulk thanos and
the bartender's tale of woe about the
snap making his family vanish for five
years eddie becomes determined to
connect with spider-man in new york
unfortunately mcu fans have just enough
time to get excited about the
possibility of hardy's venom and holland
spider-man coming face to face before
eddie brock and venom are sucked back to
their own universe when doctor strange's
spell takes hold sorry marvel fans it
seems like this meetup won't be
happening anytime soon but wait eddie
does leave behind a tiny glob of black
goo on the bar undoubtedly this remnant
of venom will soon find its own host
perhaps opening the door for some sort
of dull venom storyline the scene seems
to indicate that tom hardy's venom will
continue in his own films while some
sort of symbiote storyline could soon
begin infecting the mcu
if you stick around until the very end
of all those names you won't so much see
an end credit scene so much as what is
essentially a trailer for doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness it seems
unlikely this will disappoint you in any
way however as the trailer looks amazing
we can't show it here but here's the
gist dr strange is told your desecration
will not go unpunished clearly facing
the repercussions of the spells he casts
on behalf of his spider friend in a
series of quick images we see doctor
strange dealing with fractured
narratives and competing realities
including a shot of dr christine palmer
getting married but perhaps the most
exciting moment comes when strange
journeys to some remote tree lines
location to solicit help from wonder
maximoff last seen in one division
terrorizing the residents of a small
town or grappling with their own
dangerous tenuous grip on reality wonder
admits she made mistakes but doctor
strange says he's not there to talk
about what's happened in westview after
a few more glimpses of plot points that
seem unsettling to say the least doctor
strange is told the greatest threat to
our universe is is you then an evil
doctor strange appears like the one in
what earth delivering the ominous line
things just got out of hand we'll have
to wait until may 6 2022 to find out
what this all means when doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness it's
theaters check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about spider-man no way home are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you